you ever squeeze lemons like mine
easy-peasy I hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to SCP
containment breach now I know it's been
a while since the last episode it will
not be that long between each subsequent
episode from now on now we just got out
of scp-989 we got some medical hypose we
got a large bandage and we've got the
our argon which we can put into the
container for the butterflies or the
dragons dragons butterflies ah that's
fine it's all good baby baby so good all
I gotta do now is remember exactly where
I needed to go which I don't quite
remember I actually have no idea where
I'm going so I know that my greatest
objective isn't exactly necessitated to
get the dragons free how many god damn
airlocks
how many Frick frack airlocks do you
need anyway not the point the point is
that I find a way out here it's just
endless hallways oh my god it's endless
hallways ah magical Larry's gonna really
god damn you why does this man have the
world's longest blinks I've ever seen of
any human
no one's ever blinked okay I died I hope
that when I actually die I have the
cognizance and capacity to scream out I
died I died write that on my tombstone
my last words I died I might be the
dumbest thing I've ever yelled was this
muster to kill me and I didn't even save
before I did that stupid move did I I
I didn't I bet I'd know I bet I didn't
oh no I did oh no I didn't wait where
where am I all right but maybe maybe
you'll the mule Billy's gone Oh Billy
and I hear Billy up saw I see all right
cool ooh hey this is actually pretty
good so there might be some good stuff
in here SCP foe that's the cure
everything pill yes yes I don't know
what I'm gonna use it to cure Oh the
ring of Defense that's a good ring it'll
make me tired but it'll also protect me
from the medic effects oh wait no let's
tell it's a wrong ring oh I don't feel
so good wait was that the wrong ring no
okay I'm good I'm good it's all good
baby it's the protective ring hot duck
oh I should not touch anomalous
materials I just shouldn't do it I
should learn that by touching things I
inadvertently do myself always this
forever duck please please duck okay
thank you
Thank You duck Thank You duck thank you
for a peer into the beyond of the x-ray
I don't know if it was exactly x-rays
that I was seeing but it was it was that
was great I'm just gonna save perfect
okay okay okay I'm gonna I did not
expect him to be there I'm fine
is he still there
hi okay ah gonna move gonna move gonna
move oh I don't have time for this
no no no no oh I'm alive I'm alive a
bullet hole on the left post suck on I
don't know what I don't know what I was
stuck on okay we're fine we're fine
we're fine we're fine good oh that was
awful
oh hey Robo how are you doing good to
see you man that sucked
great love that that was great
had a good time CPD $14.99 okay I don't
know what you are
what is scp-1498 the hell warehouse has
keycard someone tell Anderson to speak
with them about it oh it's the gas mask
holy crap oh oh oh no no no not like
this
no this is the worst I'm out of run
juice that's great hey good stuff man
911 for I was wrong about the number
great stuff this is going great
alright so what I've learned is exactly
nothing I've learned that there's a
keycard in the warehouse which helps me
oh yeah
sir plane even to coming in here I see
it's not like I see this in a like a
checkpoint explodes out of the ground oh
okay alright we're fine it's fine
everything's fine
no no not like that please I know that's
Billy whoa you suck so hard
oh my blam blam blum blum Liberty
Liberty Balu
oh no wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait let me let me
catch my breath
this is great great stuff great a plus a
plus Omega which way my god I don't know
I just I'm not gonna go I'm just not
going to go is the answer I won't go I'd
refused to go that's the thing about
that
no sir sir sir sir sir Sir sir well sir
sir sir sir Oh oh that's not good
wait no this bed wait wait wait no no no
no no no no my eyes shove it in my balls
I don't care shove it in me somehow whoa
decontamination hell I should never have
come down here oh no oh no oh no no no
no no oh no no no oh no how do I get
away from me
how do I get away am I free huh
I regret suggesting that I should shove
a hypo needle into my testicles I feel
like of all the takeaways from my many
videos that will be one that people
remember for a no apparent reason it's
not my fault that in a panic I think
illogically it is not my fault I cannot
be held accountable for the things I say
when I am spoo peed understand good
we're all in agreement that we will
collectively forget now that we got that
out of the way let me shove another
bandage in my testicles I'm gonna go
over this right zero I will go up
I cannot go up I will go opposite of
this oh I can't go office I didn't think
I could go up it right like containment
zone sublevel one that's the good [ __ ]
hello excellent archival storage staff
offices level one I'm just gonna get an
idea of what's around I remember there
being something that I need to find
besides the warehouse there's gotta be
something else that I can get I do like
the new layout of these places this is
pretty cool they really did a good job
Skyrim cafeteria loud security office I
needed to go to the Security office oh
hello I'm young how are you good to see
you
thank God they left me alone for at
least a little bit I've even got space
heaters here it's awfully nice except
this just loops great for running away
from people well this looks really nice
and the walls aren't blood-stained at
all almost makes me think there wasn't a
horrible containment breach with
monsters the likes of which my mind
could never comprehend Wow lovely this
is just lovely divine can I get out here
this where I can get out ding-dong hi
oh no this is the ahh I know what this
is is that cafeteria that's like
upstairs I don't think there's anything
useful up here except maybe an encounter
who's he what's it no no no no no you're
not pulling a siren head on me he's not
an SCP you can't bring him into this you
just can you're not allowed
it's not allowed why are you trying I
got the security off his key what are
you can't ask you tip you tit you and
you asked it I'll give you some of this
and one of these that's what I thought
yeah I'll casually you know I need to
run no I need to run oh ho that oh
that's not good Wow yeah you bundle of
balls Oh what the hell was that my
friend
I mean you missed [ __ ] hmm oh you suck
oh you suck okay I'm going in ears to
hear oh yeah yeah yeah
Zappa D oh yeah yeah keep me keep me
keep me here get zapped yeah yeah come
at me no don't don't skip it don't skip
it don't skip it in there oh you suck oh
my god you're getting it again oh baby
okay I've got cops about to say security
off his key if only - for security
vandalize a security office looking in
support one yeah I have I have the key
but I've got the key sounds like you
need a voice thing somewhat that needs
somebody doesn't need a voice hi why am
I not running oh god the goop on the
ground I almost forgot about the goop
Oh interesting that my field of view get
more narrow my eyeballs change feel like
my eyeballs have changed hey bud how you
doing how you doing bud good great good
this is great this is going swimmingly
this is about the best I could have ever
hoped for sure I'm glad all of this is
happening okay we're gonna do this we're
doing this we're doing this all they
give me less time on the blink that's
fine
cuz maybe that wasn't the Security
office maybe that was just a security
checkpoint maybe the key that I have
goes to the actual office which would be
a place and not just a stupid gate you
know I mean you know I mean yeah you
know I mean yeah you all know I mean
yeah Oh baby this feels like progress oh
oh come on right there suck Davis
Campbell said he was gonna take his
break early if you need anything you can
find him upstairs in the Skyrim
cafeteria
Oh buddy Oh perfect this is what you
call perfect thank you thank you thank
you thank you well no I didn't want that
opened thank you thank you all right
what do we have a year ooh
Tesla gate monitoring
why is this open I closed that right I
closed that Lexi and I closed that right
[Music]
okay great
all right okay so do I want to disable
the Tesla Cates is the thing I don't
even have my I don't even have that
unlock the Tesla offices hi why do we
need a prison a series for guide how to
avoid disaster maybe it's not prison
maybe it's actually select beds probably
not a prisons not a person all right
cool good
all right let's let's well all right
here we go
never mind never mind never mind okay
let's try this
ah I'm going I'm going I'm going I'm
going
get it get it get it get it oh god
where's the door I hate it oh I'm being
a bit of a [ __ ] saver but obviously
it's for good reason Tesla office should
be able to get in there now
oh it goes on a little longer than I
like okay let there be light
what do we got anything good anything
good no nothing good all right great
laughs I went in here large bin dude
you're really shitty small bandages up
might as well use one am i right yeah
why else did I come in here I mean a
large bend dudes is helpful was that Oh
BAM almost missed that all right let's
get you out here turn off the light save
power I don't think so I could have gone
all right all right easy peasy zzzzzz
LEM squeeze my squeeze squeeze my lemons
hey you ever squeeze lemons like mine
easy peasy aye
all right the door was open oh yeah
Easy Pieces easy puzzle ease yeah you
never posed in easier position what that
pursues was all there to squeeze my
lemonis I do around
okay so archival storage and staff
office it's going great right it's going
great
unhappy load a new cluster buoy here we
go all right maybe I should just leave
these open it's not like it benefits me
to keep them closed at all it really
doesn't okay staff offices I don't know
if there's gonna help me cuz like
whatever I'm running away or I need to
run past Billy I need to open kind of
kind of do anyway I don't know if it's
absolutely well this isn't what he's I
was expecting exactly oh it's beautiful
it was lovely whoa this would trick me
it's uh it's delightful I like this they
sure do treat their staff nicely and you
you know considering all the PTSD they
must go through they had better you know
they better give them something nice you
know I would have figured that this
place would have been a bit more
utilitarian but no hello anything useful
in here everyone leaves their lights on
it's like they don't care about the
power
oh hi oh is it oh wait is this the this
is the patreon offices that's right they
do they give entry on people some
offices that's right they do they do
they do I don't know if there's anything
good in here wait what that's great
that's great that's good that's good
that's good stuff
hi well that's cute that's cute that's
cute
Danielle perfect oh oh look at that's
nice that's so nice oh I thought that
was actually gonna have something in it
oh yeah well that's that was nice that
helped me in the game at all we've got
that was a nice reprieve from the
horrible monstrosity that were trying to
eat my face how'd he get up there ah
interesting is there way never oh not
that was lovely that was a lovely little
break now back into the middle of it and
I'm assuming everything's gonna try to
kill me as fast as Sun humanly possible
hello I'm ready for death huh all right
archival storage
I am leaving everything opened why hey I
just saved you I just saved you can't
you can't it's not allowed no no the
rules you must play you must rule what
what is that scoop to my Lou scooty Lou
skroob to my Lube scoop it scoop my
loops stupid don't scoop ah what the
hell the hell oh no no no no I was
standing there I was stand on scoop
no scoops okay no scoops ah you in here
you in there I don't want to go
downstairs that's the thing I I didn't I
don't wanna
oh okay that's okay this is okay it's
the first sucks you don't remember the
birthday monkey the birthday monkey if
you don't think happy birthday Wow
that's right happy birthday to you happy
birthday happy birthday it sure is to
you happy birthday to you happy birthday
happy birthday happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you happy birthday happy birthday happy
birthday to you oh I got candy yeah I
can't
YUM thank you so what the happy birthday
monkey does is if you don't single
actually if you do or don't every time
it plays its song it will take like a
year of your life away from you and
depending on if you sing along with it
or how well you sing along with it the
candy will give back that life there's
only been one case where someone was so
enthusiastic like for every verse of
like 99 verse was like oh [ __ ] was like
and they sang incredibly I think they
actually ended up getting a year back Oh
candy speaking of candy no more than two
please or as you have your arms chopped
off I don't need you I've done that so
many times I don't need to show it again
yeah oh so there's also there's also an
SCP that is a sheet like a Halloween
sheep ghost costume that if you put it
on nothing will happen right away but if
you while wearing it go woo you'll start
raising up in the wonderful until you
get to the part of the story where
there's like the horrible ghosts that
actually start haunting you and then you
face through walls and then halfway
through the wall you can stop saying
whoo and I always like most SUVs there
are ways to horribly die on everything
either way this is a nice reprieve I'm
gonna stop this episode here because
okay you're done great that's good
that's good so thank you everybody so
much for watching
they've done so many improvements on
this version of the game I'm gonna be
playing this again real soon don't you
worry about a thing every little thing
is gonna be alright they it's a lot more
panic-inducing
it's about the same level of
panic-inducing as the original SCP
containment breach was and I think
that's good that they got to that point
Billy is a dick and radical Larry is a
bigger dick I like his scoop radical
Larry he's got the scoops you know I'm
talking about daddy got the scoops
anyway thank you
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]